pour le groupe les républicains merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi de l'insertion
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
vient de présenter sa réforme des
retraites et le moins que l'on puisse
dire et que les femmes pourraient être
les grandes perdantes des mesures à
venir l'étude d'impact le démontre
clairement elles devront travailler en
moyenne 7 mois de plus alors que les
hommes ne seront astreints à 5 mois
supplémentaires en outre de nombreuses
femmes pouvaient partir dès 62 ans à
taux plein grâce au trimestre à qui lors
de la naissance de leurs enfants avec
votre réforme elles devront travailler
deux ans de plus pour atteindre le
nouvel âge légal de 64 ans et perdront
le bénéfice de cette bonification vous
aurez beau jeu de souligner qu'en
travaillant plus longtemps et
bénéficieront d'une retraite de
revaloriser vous ne manquerez pas de
rappeler également quels seront les
premières bénéficiaires de la hausse au
minimum de la pension du minimum de
pension mais de quelle retraite
parlons-nous vous n'ignorez pas que la
retraite des femmes est de 40%
inférieure à celle des hommes parce les
premières victimes des inégalités
salariales vous ne pouvez ignorer non
plus qu’elles ont des carrières
fréquemment interrompues par des
maternités qui réduisent la durée de
cotisation et fond d'elle les plus
touchées par la décote dans ces
conditions il est indispensable de
compenser les forces supplémentaires
demandées aux femmes de mieux en prendre
en compte leur maternité car une réforme
des retraites par répartition ne peut se
désintéresser de la politique familiale
et d'avancer l'âge de la décote à ce
stade du projet loi et avant les
discussions parlementaires ces mesures
nous paraissent plus équitables que
l'allongement de la durée de vie active
pour améliorer le taux de pension
êtes-vous prêt monsieur le ministre à
corriger ces injustices qui concernent
les femmes et que notre groupe a déjà
pointé à plusieurs reprises sur un sujet
aussi grave nous aurons à cœur de
trouver en la majorité sénatoriale comme
à notre habitude une solution de
compromis acceptable par tous je vous
remercie pour votre réponse
monsieur le ministre du Travail le
emploi de l'insertion je vous donne la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice darkos d'abord vous
avez raison sur un point en particulier
qui est je crois fondamental dans ce
débat sur les retraites et sur les
inégalités de niveau de retraite entre
les femmes et les hommes aujourd'hui 50%
des femmes retraitées ont une retraite
inférieure à 1000 euros brut parce que
c'est la conséquence l'effet miroir
d'une inégalité face au travail d'une
égalité face au salaire et ce mouvement
sociologique que nous connaissons
d'augmentation du taux d'activités
d'augmentation du taux d'emploi des
femmes corrige petit à petit et bien
trop lentement cette inégalité qui est
simplement le fruit des inégalités
professionnelles et de carrière c'est là
peut-être la priorité rétablir l'égalité
professionnelle pour que n'ayons pas au
moment des départs à la retraite à
imaginer à penser des systèmes de
retraite qui soit en réalité des
systèmes qui viennent corriger des
inégalités accumulées tout au long de la
vie nous avons dans le projet qu'elle
notre un effort qui est demandé à tous
les salariés
quel que soit leur cadre d'emploi quel
que soit leur campemploi privé public
régime
nous savons que le départ effectif l'âge
de départ effectif des femmes va se
rapprocher de celui des hommes même si
je les dis tout à l'heure l'âge moyen de
départ des femmes restera inférieur à
celui des hommes nous avons voulu
apporter des corrections et des
protections j'ai évoqué la question de
la retraite minimum vous l'avez fait
vous-même je pourrais évoquer par
exemple ou révoquer le fait que nous
allons intégrer dans les trimestres
prises en compte les trimestres cotisés
au titre de l'assurance vieillesse pour
les parents au foyer cela concerne un
million 900 000 femmes notamment parmi
les moins favorisés tant pour les
éligibilité au minimum de pension que
pour les éligibilité au départ anticipé
pour carrière longue nous avons
certainement encore du travail à faire
autour de la question des aidants nous
allons créer cette assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants ce sont souvent des
femmes nous avons aussi un travail à
faire pour harmoniser les droits comment
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui une maternité
soit génératrice si je puis dire de 4
trimestres de manière automatique au
titre du régime général et de deux au
titre de la fonction publique nous avons
d'ores et déjà demandé avec madame la
Première ministre au Conseil
d'orientation des retraites d'ouvrir un
chantier sur ce sujet là j'espère que
les débats parlementaires nous permettra
d'avancer sur cette question des droits
familiaux sur cette question de la
parentalité de la maternité mais aussi
sur les questions de réversion le texte
tel qu'il sera adopté je l'espère par
l'Assemblée nationale nous permettra
certainement de construire des consensus
merci Monsieur ministre j'entends ce que
vous dites et en effet
vous allez déjà revaloriser en effet les
plus les plus retraite mais on voudrait
pouvoir également parler au nom de
toutes ces femmes qui travaillent depuis
longtemps qui ont des beaux Jobs et qui
ont eu des moments aussi formidables de
d'arrêt avec avec leurs congés maternité
donc de toutes les secteurs d'activité
je parle aussi bien évidemment des des
femmes dans le milieu de l'agriculture
la délégation a fait déjà beaucoup dans
d'autres dans plein de secteurs et donc
je vous inviterai avec la secrétaire de
Madame Rome à pouvoir regarder nos
rapports et nos projets pour pouvoir
également construire la fin de ce projet
de loi sur les retraites tous ensemble